Welcome back everyone this will be my doctor
strange 2 video for iron man the illuminati
some of the deleted scenes and members of the
team that they had tried to include previously
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there are so many things that we need to talk
about and i'm still doing the giveaway for imax
tickets for the movie all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber and post
all your theories about them introducing those
teams from the illuminati in the future the mcu
everybody cannot wait for more fantastic four
more x-men more inhumans everybody asking lots of
questions about the inhumans finally they answered
it that was one of the big surprises of the film
but during the movie they introduce a version of
marvel's illuminati from an alternate universe
838 the number designation 838 isn't meant to be
a direct reference to the actual illuminati team
in the comics but the writer kevin feige talked
about the entire team and this just part of the
movie in general explaining how they use the team
itself and what they changed the roster that they
changed when they brought on the new writer the
new director sam raimi himself to do the movie
because originally the team was always going to
be part of the film but in the original version
of the movie they had a different roster and they
used the team in a very different way so during
the final version of the movie we saw in theaters
the illuminati's home base is basically their
universe's version of professor x's x-mansion from
the comics so it's inside central park the world
had been turned into this utopia after the events
of their version of avengers infinity war because
of what the illuminati team did differently from
our mcu version of the avengers for the most part
the vibe of the team in the way they operate the
big things that they do the hard choices that they
make are similar to the comic book version but
the roster is different from the comic book roster
the version of the team that we actually see
in the movie is john krasinski's reed richards
of the fantastic four he's married to a version
of sue storm in recent interviews they actually
legit make it sound like emily blunt is their
version of sue storm in this universe he has
both children from the comics franklin richards
valeria richards franklin richards is like the
most powerful human character that marvel has
ever introduced next to really big cosmic concepts
they have patrick stewart professor x coming
back who's playing a version very similar to
the one from x-men the animated series all the
major x-men the mutants exist in this universe
like wolverine cyclops jean greystorm because
they're going with an x-men that animated series
vibe you also have to assume that they all wear
very comic booky 80s 90s looking costumes too
like the version of the wolverine costume that's
meant to be comic book accurate from that deleted
scene in the wolverine movie they have a version
of ants and mounts black bull to the inhumans
who's playing a different version than the one
he played on the tv show but in this universe
inhumans the church and myths are commonplace they
have a maria rambeau captain marvel variant she's
monica rambeau's mother she was also a test
pilot she was carol danvers best friend she
just happened to be the test pilot on the day that
they were testing that tesseract ship so she's the
one that got in the accident she's the one that
got the powers hilly atwell captain carter who's
playing a different version than the one from what
if but exact same backstory baron mordo of their
universe has become sorcerer supreme replacing
their doctor strange on the team when they killed
him during their version of infinity war which
happened after they used the book of the vashanti
to kill their thanos preventing him from snapping
their infinity gauntlet so in their universe they
never had a snap never had a five year time jump
and they just lied to the world to make them think
that their doctor strange died a hero instead of
being corrupted by their version of the darkhold
so everybody was wondering what was going on
with that sixth empty chair like there were seven
spaces but there was a space for professor x's
chair which means that the empty chair belonged to
a completely different member and they basically
confirmed our theories that it was a version of
iron man but there was a big question about
who was going to be playing that version of
iron man and that was what they were talking
about mostly like what their original plan was
for the character and what changed about that they
answered a lot of big rumors that had been going
around the past year too we had all those ultron
robot variants of the iron legion that were a huge
plot point during all these scenes you may have
heard them verbally reference the ultron protocol
the voice of the robots themselves was actually
ross mark hand who played their version of red
skull during avengers infinity war avengers end
game and then again during what if they were meant
to be upgrades of this version of iron man's iron
legion in this universe so for example another
big thing that was different in this universe is
that they didn't have their version of avengers
age of voltron because their iron man was able
to control their ultron technology when they
found their version of the mine stone so they had
a version of iron man in this universe where is he
what happened to him why is this empty chair
here i saw a few comments of people wondering
whether or not the ultron robots came from another
character like hank pym because in the comics hank
pym is the person who created ultron it wasn't
tony stark they changed that for the movies
people wondering can maybe reed richards change
them because he's the smartest man alive he'd have
the ability to do something like that and they
basically said that that was never a thing like it
wasn't their version of hank pym or reed richards
or anything like that it was all meant to be very
iron man specific kind of stuff on the team in
general so their iron man did create these robots
their writer says that they always wanted
to include a version of iron man in some way
but when he came on board and they were writing a
new version of the movie one of the changes that
he made initially was the legitimate tom cruise
iron man in a cameo scene so if you saw any kind
of rumors about tom cruise playing a version
of iron man earlier this year or last year
that's where those rumors probably came from
legit they actually tried to make it happen
the reason why that's meant to be a big easter
egg for the origin of the iron man character of
the mcu is that originally there was a version
of the iron man movie that they tried to make
with tom cruise before robert danny jr and john
favreau came onto the project obviously i think
they made the right call like it was correct for
tom cruise to turn down the role now anytime you
mention the iron man name you can't help but think
of robert downey jr so it would be really weird
to see another actor playing that role but the
main reason why you didn't see tom cruise doing
a cameo scene in the movie because he's known for
doing really weird one-off cameos things like what
is he doing in this movie why is he doing this
cameo it just turns out he does stuff like that
the main reason why it didn't work out in this
movie is mostly because of the virus because they
were filming this movie during the virus it caused
a bunch of scheduling conflicts and tom cruise was
mostly stuck filming his mission impossible
movies during the pandemic so if you want to
blame anything for them not being able to get a
tom cruise cameo blame the virus which i think
is probably the best way to go it wasn't about him
never wanting to be in a marvel movie or anything
like that he probably would have actually done
it had it not been for the scheduling conflicts
then after that wound up falling through during
the process of them making the movie they just
decided to leave their version of iron man in this
universe up in the air like not directly address
him just to make people wonder because they were
already introducing so many twists with all the
new fantastic four the x-men the inhuman stuff so
yes iron man was a part of the movie but that's
why you don't actually see him on screen like his
presence is meant to be felt through the ultron
robots and through a lot of what's going on here
theoretically he's still alive in this universe
and they just kind of use their hand wavy logic to
explain why he doesn't happen to be sitting here
with the rest of the team when all the events of
the movie go down i also think behind the scenes
when this started to happen they just decided that
if they were going to do a legit version of iron
man variant on screen they just eventually decided
to wait until actual secret wars takes place to
bring robert downey jr back in different forms
like they'll continue to reference mcu iron man
in different ways through the different projects
like iron man's armor war series is happening
in the next year or two they're gonna have to
reference a lot of iron man mcu stuff during that
the whole plot hinges on another villain stealing
iron man's technology a classic marvel story about
tony stark's worst fear coming true it's what
happens when his tech falls into the wrong hands
so i think when we get through our time runs out
movie then we get to our actual secret wars movie
then they'll bring back live-action robert downey
jr in some form i also think they'll eventually
try to pay off that big sorcerer supreme tony
stark twist from avengers infinity war in that
deleted scene this is legit footage that they
shot just turned into a deleted scene they just
never released it online before i've already done
a bunch of videos about this avengers infinity war
deleted scenes we'll post links in the description
iron man becoming a version of sorcerer's supreme
and dr strange becoming a version of iron man
wearing the armor he was called the iron mage
when he wore iron man's armor what the writer said
though is that one of the other big things that
he changed with the actual team when they were
trying to decide who was going to be on the team
what they were going to do with them during the
movie is that the stuff that they did with them
in this draft was way crazier than what they
were doing in the original draft of the movie
it sounds like when he came onto the film he had
all this plot with him trying to stop wanda and
her killing them like originally they were a much
smaller part of the film and they didn't all wind
up dying so quickly so i think in the original
version they probably did not have anson mount
black bolt or the maria rambeau captain marvel
variant the writer also said that they're using
the same type of pacing now in marvel phase four
with the incursions and secret wars that they used
with thanos and the infinity gauntlet the infinity
gems during marvel phase one phase two and phase
three like they introduced the multiverse in
a big way is a big trope during spider man no
way home doctor strange multiverse of madness
then they tease the incursions then they do
time runs out then they do secret wars the same
way that you tease space in the first thor movie
then you tease space coming to them with the
chitauri invasion the first avengers movie and
then by the time you get to avengers infinity
war you have actual thanos coming for them with
the infinity gauntlet so just based on that pacing
it seems like there's going to be a time runs out
avengers style movie like a big crossover film if
it's not avengers they'll call it something else
like that would be avengers 5 where they all work
together to stop the incursions in a big way but
fail to do so and things get worse and worse
and worse until there's only the fragments of
a couple universes left then they combine them
and in the next big crossover movie avengers 6
or whatever they wind up calling it that winds up
being the secret wars film the russos themselves
actually even said that they would probably
be doing something like this way back when
infinity war happened like wouldn't it be cool
if we did this the writer was michael waldron
he's the person who created the loki tv series
he did all the tva stuff i know there's a lot
of questions about why the tva didn't get totally
involved in the plot of the film he explained that
too i'll talk about it in a separate video
because it's a completely separate thing
he also had a cameo scene in the movie as the
best man at mcu christine palmer's wedding if
you don't remember i've got a bunch more doctor
strange two videos planned i'll talk about some
of the really big twists in the movie over
the next couple of days so if you have any
big questions or requests just write them in
the comments below i'll name a giveaway winner
in my next big marvel video everyone click
here for my full doctor strange 2 breakdown
easter eggs for the entire movie and click here
for my doctor strange 2 post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!